for some reason I've been getting a lot
of requests for me to speak in Turkish
in my Vlogs I thought I'd satisfy all of
those by speaking to my friend yen in
Turkish and we're going to explore
London try out some delicious Turkish
food which is something I'm really
excited about actually the same I'm
ready I'm ready
this feels so weird
I know you can't just okay wait hold on
would you even just say just now I won't
tell you what so I'm just supposed to
answer you without knowing what you're
saying yeah you should have tried to
learn some more Turkish I told you I was
gonna film then you act like you learn
Chinese when we filmed that other videos
Banyan
kinda okay it was given that I was gonna
ask you that question I don't think he
understood actually
wait what else could I say just give me
a few phrases so I don't look stupid
but I cannot say this in Turkish so I'm
currently doing clinical biochemistry
foreign
[Music]
you think I know how to speak say all
that in Turkish
okay
I'm just gonna ask you some normal stuff
I don't know
the restaurant again
foreign
you have to
I told you this yeah but that's to a
real person
because it's just such highly
respectable drink in Turkey
yeah
I know you're thanking me
is
foreign
[Music]
skip this
I like it
um
right
[Music]
now
yours yeah
yeah no each person sends to a chested
[Music]
Mayfair today
it's good
[Music]
chilling
what is chilling in Turkish
yeah all this is
uh how about
another summer teachers
is that all you know can you give me
some more here so I can work with it I
don't even know what you're talking
about all I can say is yes we should
teach me something
how do you say hi yeah such
gazelle what do you what are you trying
to say your hair looks beautiful yeah
thank you my hair is a mess called this
beautiful you called this gizzard this
guy well uh
okay I think something that we really
need to work on yen is your
pronunciation
really yeah okay so for example
yeah can you say yeah
that was good okay I feel like you can't
really say it
but you kind of say a little bit like
bro okay say like can you do this
no try it anyway
I'm not built like this you're not built
like that that's fine
[Music]
um
what did I say that word is a bad word
oh yeah
she
teach okay
um
to chase everyone
you actually understood how does Turkish
sound like to you look it's our use a
lot of tongue a little bit throat I feel
like Turkish people used to be kind of
fast
[Music]
September
um
said
yeah
how do you think was the end why am I
translating it for you oh is it
chocolate yeah but you've been over
using that I think you need to you need
to increase I remember you were just
overusing some Chinese words
um choc choc is it oh yeah that
literally added that extra spice we
needed Chop Chop how would you rate your
Turkish learning experience the color I
did learn a lot of vocabularies today
that's it honestly that's all you plan
on YouTube
anyway still learn something from today
and it was really fun so kind of fell
was really nice I love her
English